c'est une histoire qui ne laisse
personne indifférente puis je pense
qu'il faut que je prenne le temps les
secondes qu'il faut pour la résumer par
c'est une situation quand même
dramatique et complexe c'est l'histoire
d'une jeune femme qui avait besoin
d'aide mais qui ne l'a pas reçu vous la
voyez ici à mili champagne 22 ans elle
souffrait d'une profonde détresse une
grande anxiété et pendant de longues
années on a cherché la cause des mots
qui l’affligeait on a eu toutes sortes
d'hypothèses et finalement il y a des
médecins qui ont trouvé au mois de juin
c'est la maladie de Lyme c'est une
maladie qui se traite mais Amélie
souffrait toujours d'anxiété d'un mal le
profond situation c'est vraiment dégradé
au coin au point ou à la manifester
exprimer des pensées suicidaires à son
frère elle voulait qu'il lui fasse un
nœud coulant elle a été amenée à
l'hôpital d'augluze un psychiatre la vue
c'est 25 minutes lui a prescrit des
pilules pour dormir on sait pas ce que
c'est dit entre la patiente mêler le
psychiatre parce que même les parents ce
ne sont pas là à ce moment là on sait
pas donc on peut pas rien conclure de ça
mais Amélie va faire une autre va faire
vraiment une tentative de suicide dans
un lac en esterie puis cette ensevelure
va l'amener à l'urgence de l'hôpital de
Sherbrooke elle va passer trois jours de
nuit sur une civière
dans des conditions affreuses atroces
personne de sain d'esprit voudrait
passer ce temps-là sur une civière à
côté de gens qui sont en crise alors
qu'elle manque de sommeil Amélie ne peut
pas être prise en charge sur place c'est
à dire à l'hôpital
pourquoi on a invoqué la pratique
habituelle c'est ça que on va se poser
la question elle avait le mauvais code
postal parce que son adresse est à
Montréal l'hôpital de Sherbrooke avec
une urgence débordée puis pas un sans
doute pas de lit on peut pas vous
prendre pas le bon code postal allez
vous à Montréal mais pour être un forum
à Montréal ça se fait pas jusqu'en des
doigts elle a voulu sortir de l'urgence
tellement c'est un tolérable
concentrer chez ses parents qui l'ont
entouré d'amour de tous les soins de
tous les câlins tous les beaux mots
d'amour elle devait rentrer à Notre-Dame
à Montréal le lundi matin les réparable
s'est produit elle a donc c'est donc
enlevé la vie longue septembre à
Montréal et voici ce que son père Alain
Champagne a dit au micro de Paul Arcan
du 98,5 ce matin
c'est complètement inacceptable de
cogner des portes de défoncer des portes
comme on le fait de se faire rejeter
comme ça non de se faire dire que ma
fille est pas en danger immédiat pour
elle-même alors qu'elle vient de tenter
de se noyer deux jours avant qu'il n'a
pas dormi on me le retourne dans un pire
état qu'avant
juste quelques heures après c'est quoi
la définition d'une médias
5 heures 10 heures c'est quoi pour moi
c'est c'est une situation qui
est d'avoir vécu les funérailles dans ma
fille en fin de semaine ça événement qui
aurait jamais dû arriver mon message au
décideur c'est prenez action c'est
deux belles opportunités à Sherbrooke de
prendre une patiente en charge qui parle
ouvertement le suicider ou qui vient de
faire une tentative
puis on le fait pour
défoncé des portes puis
le système rejette les patients c'est ce
qu'on a vécu je peux généraliser c'est
ce qu'on a vécu malheureusement les
signaux très clairs
le père a le courage d'interpeller les
autorités on a réagit aujourd'hui le
coronaire en chef déclaré qu'il y aurait
une enquête publique du coronaire sur la
mort d'Amélie champagne et on s'est
tourné nous vers les autorités Lionel
Karman il est sorti à la science à la
santé au service sociaux docteur karma
parce que vous êtes médecin en plus vous
connaissez aussi la situation interne
des hôpitaux c'est inacceptable c'est un
dessin acceptable
c'est ce qui s'est passé surtout ce
sentiment d'être rejeté que Monsieur
champagne décrit c'est inacceptable et
c'est pour ça que dès hier soir on a
demandé de lancer une enquête publique
vous ressentez vous reconnaissez ce que
le perdit elle a été rejetée par le
système le fait qu'il ait eu ce
sentiment là c'est inacceptable il faut
aller au fond des choses aller au fond
des choses alors récapitulons bon est
allé l'hôpital de glue elle ressent
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé là
l'enquête du corner va nous Ré mais
arrivé dans une urgence en psychiatrie
après une tentative de suicide se
retrouver trois jours et de nuit dans le
chaos total avec des gens en psychose
elle voulait sortir de là vous et moi on
pourrait pas supporter ça et elle elle
est malade alors comment comment c'était
un manque de sommeil et donc cette fois
que je comprenne qu'est-ce qu'il y a
motivé cette décision là et pourquoi on
est arrivé là
sont dans cet état-là parce que ça
détresse c'est pas du sang qu'on voit ça
les avait saigner on l'aurait tout de
suite soigné mais ça détresse est
invisible et le commence ma question
c'est comment se fait-il que nos
urgences psychiatriques sont dans cet
état là il y a deux choses premièrement
vu les le triage à l'urgence les
problèmes psychiatriques sont souvent
gérés en P4 P5 donc des délais très très
longs avant d'être évalués ensuite il y
a une deuxième problématique c'est que
les les durées de séjour des patients en
psychiatrie sont extrêmement
alors nous on propose de solutions dans
notre plan d'action c'est un mètre un
guichet à l'urgence avec infirmière
travailleuse sociale et des intervenants
communautaires pour non seulement
évaluer la situation mais s'assurer
d'une continuité dans la communauté puis
deuxièmement je pense que c'est
important d'en parler on a fait une
annonce aussi d'hospitalisation à
domicile il faut diminuer les
hospitalisations en psychiatrie qui dure
extrêmement longtemps elle était très
bien entourée par sa famille le père
s'est même levé pour voir certaines dans
son lit puis quelques minutes après
c'était jeté du 16e étage là mais ma
question c'est comment alors ça fait
trop longtemps que les urgences en
psychiatrie sont aussi inospitalières
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a un
reportage comme ça c'est parce que les
patients d'urgence attendent d'être
avoir un lit il y a pas assez de
litres
la situation psychiatrie c'est la même
que que dans le reste du réseau les lits
sont membres de personnel aussi avec les
enjeux covid donc c'est la même
situation alors
elle avait le mauvais code postal vous
rejetez cette pratique là ou pas je la
comprends pas c'est la patiente est
prise en charge à l'hôpital aux urgences
il faut que la situation soit bien
éclaircie pour expliquer pourquoi on la
dit tout simplement parce qu'on veut la
transférer à notre hôpital surtout quand
l'hôpital n'a pas de lit disponible si
j'ai bien compris la situation donc
j'aurais pu avoir un transfert d'hôpital
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est ce qu'on a
besoin de comprendre mais vous savez que
très souvent puis je vais vous situer un
autre cas tout à l'heure celui dans
l'anaudière le jeune Samuel Santos la
mère au témoigné il y a quelques
semaines c'est arrivé au début de
l'année c'est une pratique qui se fait
dans les hôpitaux pour dire ben on a
assez de monde ici aller donc faire
soigner ailleurs on le savait ce qu'on
applique cette
idée-là que l'on a le mauvais code
postal pouvez-vous changer cette
pratique là je pense que les patients
ont droit d'avoir de recevoir des soins
là où il se présente et ça c'est dans la
L4S il faut s'assurer de ça alors
pourquoi qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dire ce soir
aux gens qui auraient le mauvais code
postal et qui ont besoin de soins qui ne
les ont pas à cause de mauvais code
postal mais qu'on ne veut plus voir ce
type ce type de situation puis qu'on va
on va on va on va regarder qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans le réseau si ça arrive de
façon répétée
souvent souvent souvent souvent surtout
en santé mentale vous savez mais
peut-être en pour une prise en charge en
externe nous c'est sûr que ce qu'on veut
c'est une prise en charge dans la
communauté mais là on parle d'un cas
urgent en détresse je crois pas que ça
doit ça doit être ça doit ça doit
survenir la famille qui ne peut pas
protester contre des pratiques
administratives comme celle-là aurait pu
dire ben non vous allez l'hospitaliser
ici vous allez on va avoir un lit mais
le climat dans l'urgence était tellement
inhospitalier que ça la rendait encore
plus malade mais c'est pour ça qu'il
faut aller voir au fond des choses et
c'est pour ça qu'on a demandé l'entrée
l'enquête du coronaire pour voir quelle
pratique à causer ceci ou est-ce que le
système a failli et qu'est-ce qu'il a
changé et on va le changer et le père
dit je crois c'était au médecin résident
qui pour qui sans doute la pression très
fort si vous la laissez aller vous allez
avoir une masse sur la conscience la
famille ne voulait pas qu'on la laisse
aller voulait qu'on lui trouve un lit
non je comprends bien ça il y a des
enjeux de diagnostic psychiatrique parce
que ça effectivement aussi du manque de
lit pourquoi les unités psychiatriques
n'ont pas plus de lit disponible parce
que justement les durées de séjour en
psychiatrie sont extrêmement longues
donc il faut il faut s'assurer justement
c'est pour ça qu'on vous propose
l'hospitalisation à domicile pour que on
limite le nombre de spécialisations en
psychiatrie c'est pour ça également
qu'on veut éviter que les gens attendent
trop à l'urgence en ayant des guichets
spécialisés et un suivi dans la
communauté suite à la visite à l'urgence
je pense c'est ça qui a manqué ici
beaucoup alors la coronaire va pouvoir
enquêter tout ça convoquer qui elle veut
parce qu'enquête va être publique
exactement exactement par exemple
l'enfant la jeune adulte aurait pu être
référé vers vers un centre de crise il y
avait d'autres solutions disponibles et
c'est et ce suivi dans la communauté là
aurait dû être fait par qui à ce
moment-là parce que là les équipes de
d'urgence
sont débordés ça veut dire que l'argent
vous avez pas mis parce que les listes
d'attentes en santé mentale on ne s'est
passé de 16000 à 21000 les gens ont pas
accès à des soins
c'est sûr que après avec la pandémie il
y a une explosion de plus de 40% des
demandes les listes d'attentes sont
relativement stables le chiffre de 16000
c'est un chiffre qu'on a eu en septembre
2020 je pense qu'il était peut-être un
peu biaisé par les effets de la pandémie
le peu de consultation parce qu'en mars
on était à 19 18 19000 donc je pense que
il faut dire que les intervenantes font
un travail exceptionnel sans doute que
les médecins envers eux les médecins en
cause sont suppression aussi parce que
si en cas d'urgence psychiatriste tout
ce qu'on a à offrir c'est une civière
fait un corridor
je vous entendre là-dessus c'est faux
faire mieux je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous mais on a augmenté l'objet de
façon significative et on va continuer à
investir en santé mentale dans les
quatre dernières années on a augmenté de
700 le nombre de d'intervenants dans le
réseau de la système de la santé mentale
et on va continuer à ajouter du monde on
a promis d'ajouter 1000 intervenants au
cours des prochaines années donc on veut
travailler à bâtir je pense qu'on est le
gouvernement qui s'intéresse le plus à
la santé mentale depuis des années vous
savez moi j'ai pratiqué 24 ans à Sainte
Justine il y avait des problèmes là
d'accès aux soins depuis toujours
l'autre cas dont je vais vous parler qui
est en lien qui est presque copié-collé
à celui de d'Amélie champagne qui est
absolument dramatique mais c'est sorti
la semaine dernière dans les journaux
vous avez dû voir ça dans votre vie de
presse une marque témoigne le jeune
homme à 16 ans Samuel Santos il doit
aller
plusieurs événements l'amène à l'urgence
psychiatrique de l'hôpital Le Gardeur or
il est censé y avoir 10 pédops
qui ont démissionné depuis des mois
c'est une situation qui s'aggrave de moi
en moi et le jeune est à l'urgence
psychiatrique adulte finalement la mer
aussi voulait qu'il aille à
Sainte-Justine ou à Montréal puis il y
avait elle aussi elle avait le mauvais
code postal elle le déclarait
aujourd'hui mauvais code postal donc et
le jeune homme finalement meurt d'une
surdose parce qu'il y avait de la drogue
mais là son état il meurt à l'hôpital le
1er janvier dernier d'une surdose parce
qu'elle était traitée trop tard est-ce
que l'enquête du coronaire pourrait
examiner ce colos aussi si c'est quelque
chose qui est soulevé moi je pense que
le coronaire a toute la latitude
possible mais lorsque vous touchez c'est
le problème de demande de psychiatre et
surtout de pédopsychiatre
il y a deux psychiatres pour sensibiler
l'enfant il y en a 8 qui ont pris son
parti pourquoi ils sont partis
il y en a qui vont faire autre chose
qui prennent leur retraite on travaille
avec l'association des médecins
psychiatres sur cet exode vers le privé
des médecins psychiatres puis aussi ce
qu'on a demandé pour les régions en
pénurie psychiatre c'est qu'il y a un
regroupement qui se fasse que les
régions qui sont bien dotés comme
Montréal Québec qui viennent en aide
avec les régions où il y a une pénurie
puis pendant la pandémie des bonnes
choses c'est qu'il y a eu la
consultation télévisuelle en santé
mentale en psychiatrie puis il faut que
ça continue c'est un outil qui est utile
que les psychiatres nous ont dit mais là
ce soir en tout cas je vous ai soumis
dans le code de Madame champagne et
écriant ça vient d'arriver les parents
ont enterré leur fille en fin de semaine
le code de semelles Santos je retiens
puis je vous le soumets c'est deux cas
où le code postal a été évoqué pour pas
prendre en charge pourquoi mais parce
que les hôpitaux débordent les autres
urgences débordent un enfant puis en
plus vous êtes responsable de protection
de la jeunesse un enfant en urgence
psychiatrique adulte Sao comme un bon
sang certaines directs c'est mieux ça
que rien mais quand même non parce qu'il
y a des lieux dans les Naudières aussi
de pédopsychiatrie donc je qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé exactement dans ce dossier
là mais je pense que si c'est vraiment
un enjeu de code postal et que la
coronaire nous dit que c'est vraiment
pour ça que qu'elle n'a pu être
transférée mais on changera les choses
en temps
merci beaucoup je sais que vous êtes en
campagne électorale ça c'est un pied
dans la campagne personne ne voulait en
faire une question de partisannerie
politique c'est trop grave et peut-être
que la santé mentale c'est l'angle mort
de la santé de cours non mais c'est
important pour moi d'être là la santé
mentale a longtemps été sous-financée on
a amorcé un rapport un rattrapage
important dans les quatre dernières
années et on va continuer merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de nous parler puis on
va évidemment encore une fois on peut
voir un numéro à l'écran pour les
personnes en détresse l'appel d'aide au
suicide et puis offrir encore une fois
nos condoléances à la famille champagne
à toutes les familles touchées par la
détresse merci merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI